[Music]
all right sally well speaking of changes
tonight as more
americans get the covet 19 vaccine the
cdc is now out with these new guidelines
and they're impressive
under the cdc recommendations people who
are now fully
vaccinated can now gather with other
vaccinated people in small groups
without wearing a mask or any kind of
social distancing
and also they can visit unvaccinated
people who are deemed at low risk
now if exposed to someone with the virus
vaccinated people can skip quarantine
and testing if they're asymptomatic
we believe these new recommendations are
an important first step
to our in our efforts to redu resume
everyday activities in our communities
however we remain in the midst of a
serious pandemic
and still over 90 percent of our
population is not fully vaccinated
the cdc is asking vaccinated people to
continue to wear mass and practice
social distancing though while they are
in public and they are still advising
people to avoid medium and large
in-person gatherings
all right so we asked you on twitter
does this new cdc guidelines maybe
have you reconsider getting vaccinated
this one was pretty close 41
said yep it might change their mind 59
percent said no
brian denise for now the cdc is still
urging everyone
including those who are vaccinated to
avoid travel
the cdc says every time there's a surge
in travel there is a surge in cases
many of our variants have emerged from
uh
international places and we know that
the travel corridor is a place where
people are mixing a lot
we are really trying to restrain travel
at this current period of time
dr wilinsky adding the cdc is hopeful
the next set of guidance will have more
science around what vaccinated people
can and cannot do when it comes to
travel didn't